[Music]
and welcome back to off the record where
we talk about whatever we want we got
our boy don over here hey today what's
up don
guys
don
you um you're a military man
special operations man special ops was
it which branch of the militaries uh in
the marines marlene
marine raider right
because for some reason i thought you're
a green beret and i heard that people
don't like green berets
that's not true i said i don't like
their hats yeah it was just steve i
thought their hats are whack all green
braids i hope they hear that that's too
though i'm super ignorant to all the
cool special op stuff is there like a
hierarchy or like categorizations that
we could like delta force is the best
for us because that was where rocky was
at delta force is the best right
is that maybe i should we should hear
from him
everyone is answering except
so i mean there's us socom which is the
overarching command and then within that
there's like tiered level assets
um is socom like the harlem
globetrotters of the military where you
get every single best dude from like
different places that's the harlem
globetrotters to you and with are the
taliban like the washington general not
the scenario or the the comparison or
analogy i would go with he's like that's
too top secret i don't know that kind of
like a maybe i don't know like an
all-star
each branch
um yeah that's so cool that's so common
that's so common there's a video game on
it i played it
don't don't do the lateral for me do the
do do go this way this way so they're so
comfortable so there is a socom unit
with a little bit of like seals recon
the avengers one of the best right
it's a joy it's a joint command from all
the branches the seal i mean the navy
the marine corps
uh air force army is there a nick fury
that runs all of them yes
what's uh what's his name is george bush
but he's white
is he dissect death
sex death i'm trying to sound cool uh i
mean the secretary of defense is for the
whole department of defense um but for
so-called itself there's a commander i
can't remember i thought the
commander-in-chief was was i thought
that was the president
i mean
everything has a level right it's just
like a company so the president sits on
top are you talking about the commander
of the theater
the theater is what they call like a
whole area so like right now uh
afghanistan's a theater
um so they have a theater commander
combatant commander r-rated movie right
now got it yeah okay so so common so com
and then there's tier level assets
within it there's a whole bunch of
different units within socom right and
the army has uh what they call use eusa
socks so they have the rangers in there
some of the rangers know they have the
green berets or the green beanies in
here whack hats the marines have marsoc
which is marine special operations
command
um air force has apsock and then the
navy has nsw about aflac
right so but yeah dude who's the best
splinter cell like out of all of them
just talking shop here just between
what's the splitter
like the video game we're talking about
yeah san francisco completely different
worlds
like we live like michael ironside was
by far the best i've never played that
so i can't really relate to you on that
god
yeah michael irons he is the best dude
come on so in like in like an internal
olympics
we got everybody going against each
sector which one's gonna [ __ ] vote
i would say that each branch or each uh
division has their specialty ish but
right now he's like still waters for the
navy
yeah yeah but like right now like most
of the wars and the proxy wars and the
conflicts throughout the world they
deploy um
they pretty much everybody pretty much
has the same job for white soft which is
like the seals the green brays and the
marine readers
they all deploy together
yeah so the way it breaks down pretty
much is they deploy under what they call
a sodif so special operations task force
and with that task force commander it
could be one of any
branch right it could be a navy seal it
could be a green berry guy or it could
be um
what was this other one yeah marine
raider commander or whatever it is and
he'll control a seal team
or a platoon um a greenberry platoon so
it's all mixed up so we deploy overseas
like in afghanistan
you might have a commander that's a navy
seal but you still fall on you like you
could be a marine you could be a green
bay guy or whatever that is
dang what are you hearing from your boys
on the inside of afghanistan oh yeah
let's get into the juicy details uh the
situation's hot over there it's [ __ ]
yeah
i mean it's just this morning they had
lost 12 marines the bombing the bombings
followed by small arms fires so oh the
suicide bombing yeah think yeah just
this morning um on our time uh there was
a suicide bomb where two suicide bombers
ran into
um near the gates of
the marines that were doing like checks
for the evacuations or the evacuees yeah
um and uh they killed 12 marines and
then they started shooting after wow
into the crowd so killing injuring 13
more
um marines us marines and as well as a
[ __ ] ton of afghan holy civilians
wait so we're not fully fully out yet we
are not fully out whatsoever but they
want us to be out by august 31st right
that's what they're saying like if you
don't get out there's gonna be serious
consequences i mean but that's what they
say but then i mean i don't think the
attack that happened this morning was
provoked by the taliban i think it was
uh isis uh that did it or maybe al qaeda
small cells that did it but like they're
just trying to start up their own [ __ ]
type of thing
i think they're definitely having their
own they have their own agenda
um pushing it right is this like the
like the iraq withdrawal like under
obama where we kind of left but really
we left special forces behind no this is
like straight up vietnam withdrawal but
way way worse because i heard that other
countries everyone's leaving right like
i mean most of nato forces are going to
follow us forces right because why
because the us owns a lot of bases that
we had over there like kandahar and
bagram
major key airfields that we should have
kept while we were withdrawing right
instead of turning that over and now we
only have kabul airport to get people
out of and there's people all over the
afghanistan still u.s people i think
there's still like the camera now is 5
000 us
civilians still the white house said
that's not true so that's good news
it was four or five days ago wait what
what was that the white house said
that's not true that there's nobody left
behind but obviously you know there's a
lot of people that find
well i mean i just i saw a report today
from uh the centcom commander which is
general mckenzie so he's the theater
commander for the whole all of the
middle east right now but he just gave a
report after that bombing this morning
that said there's i think they evacuate
like 106 000 people already 106 000
ready afghans uh coming back over and
then they're trying to
evacuate 10 i'm sorry 5 000 u.s
civilians already and they're still like
5 000 left
and they're trying to help the people
that have helped the united states in
the past back because all those people
are on the taliban's hit list yeah you
know
so the situation is [ __ ] we i'm
totally unprepared too fast yeah you
were saying you were saying it's similar
to a vietnam withdrawal but
way worse way less prepared and
organized uh dive into that what is that
yeah i mean well i'm vietnamese so my
parents came over in 1975.
my parents came from vietnamese you just
said you're chinese you're the liar i
said what
is it
um from what my grandpa did i don't
think i should do that
wow
but they're they're the southern
vietnamese they're the southern they're
they're they're they're they're oh my
gosh
yeah i think we're still okay yeah okay
no we're not dude we are not okay can we
be chill use me
oh my god i'm so scared
my parents came over in 1975 after the
war after saigon fell you know and at
least america at the time had a plan to
get people out small boats to the
philippines to guam
we had a whole bunch of families
christian families catholic families
religious families um not the sponsored
people america was more pro-immigration
and refugee and they're saying yeah come
over like this is the place of refuge
now it's not the same case now it's like
don't come here and it's funny because
during the trump administration
you know he was doing the same thing
he thought biden wouldn't do the same
thing he's doing the same exact [ __ ]
yeah
and trump would just say don't come here
and then biden gets in and then kamala
harris after a couple months is like hey
just stop coming here please don't come
here
which is horrible because we spent 20
years over there billions and billions
of dollars trying to help these people
now they have a chance to get out of
that country or maybe they have a chance
or not but i believe that we should 100
help them out were you out there
in afghanistan yes i was i was there in
2012 and 2013. wow
yeah yeah my friend was um i forgot
which unit but they did something like
with bomb defusing or whatever and he
was saying like it's so weird because
it's uh
it's not western so the culture is
completely different and their education
is like non-existent so it's like
interacting with
people that look like humans but it's
like completely different like in the
country country yeah right i mean but
just like in maybe in america as well
there's maybe some ports in america that
people aren't the same as us like the
appalachian peoples yeah yeah we have
some uncontacted south carolinians
[Laughter]
since pre-columbus i mean what's that
show that tiger king yes that's the us
that's true you know that's in the
united states and i'm just like whoa
that's a whole different culture and a
tale of money and he made hell of money
yeah that was so fun one girl had a song
[ __ ] carol baskin
don what's your take on the critique
right now so everyone's saying like you
know we we spent all these billions of
dollars over so many years right but
then as soon as we leave the afghan
military falls apart what do you say
about that today's video is brought to
you by upstar
if you're like me and you dread looking
at your credit card statements you are
not alone okay there's a lot of people
like us
debt can definitely feel crippling
but upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom upstart is the fast
and easy way to pay off all of your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
upstart knows that you're more than just
your credit score
and is expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and employment to
find you a smarter rate on your loan
with a five minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars wow that's a car it's so big
monies you can receive funds as fast as
one business day after being accepted
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today by going to
upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record don't forget to use our
url so they know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and other information that
you put on your loan application go to
upstart.com off the record
everything every baby
i think that we
i mean the complex situation in
afghanistan is extremely bad right i
mean there's a [ __ ] ton of taliban
members and people hide in plain day
sites so it's not like we're fighting a
military force that has another uniform
that you can clearly identify it's like
mix in between they might be al-qaeda
they might be isis now they might be
taliban all working for the same people
different people trying to get money to
provide for their family so the
situation alone
is extremely complex but do i believe
that we went over there and did some
good i think we went over there and let
most of people in afghanistan live a
decent life for 20 years now are they
going to live a decent life probably not
so when you were out there was your
involvement like
training people or like taking out
people or like what was it all the above
right so for a special operations unit
most of them like i was talking about
before um white soft guys they go into a
place and they do what they call for an
internal fence or they do uw so they
pretty much work with train with a
foreign force and they go fight the war
with them so for us it was so they could
fight their own war so they could fight
their own war yeah so for us it was
going over with uh afghan national army
special forces unit uh we worked with
them hand-in-hand and then we went over
to these small villages and we trained
up a militia to fight the taliban or
al-qaeda at the time in their areas when
you give them mres do they get diarrhea
they never ate it before what's mre
the military well mras clog up your poop
but what about for them if they're used
to eating like goat stew all day do they
eat mre and they're like oh [ __ ] got
the [ __ ] [ __ ] myself it works yeah
they're too hot over there for goats
still
they are furry huh
i don't know no just soups in general
it's a very hot environment they should
have goat smoothies they're colder
you know like
shouldn't be goat edition yeah dude with
some matcha on the side forget about it
how long were you there for like
before afghanistan like seven months at
a time
whenever you're out there you stay there
for like pretty much half a year for one
straight time and you come back to
the states yeah so the way that the
marine corps deployments work are like
seven to nine month deployments and they
come back for or for us it was 18 months
back in the states and then you do
another deployment kind of that rotation
uh some of the conventional army units
they do like a year or 13-month
deployment so it just depends on your
unit and the job that you're going over
there too but the jobs were also
different from like special operations
like 100 yeah so what was like your like
daily life like
in afghanistan it was um i was a
communications guy so are you in a
uniform are you like undercover wearing
like some wrangler
it depends of where you're operating so
in afghanistan we wore the afghan
national army uh special forces uniforms
so you guys look like them yeah that's
why we go you gotta grow a beard i don't
grow a very good beer but the other guys
grew beards so they go you [ __ ] because
they don't they think if you don't have
a beard or a [ __ ] right or something
like that yeah just like the cultural
thing is they don't think that you're a
man so they don't speak with to you um
the same level as they would speak to
another man that would speak to you like
a boy or like kind of disrespectfully
damn you get like a santa beard maybe
figure that out i mean i had like a
nasty blue man
you just you've got a wig like a beard
wig that's my extended my beard too is a
fu manchu our friend did missionary work
in afghanistan and he grew out a beard
because everyone called them a
homosexual every day
for for having no
facial hair yeah yeah and they're right
dude and they're right
yeah bro this is the best you're gonna
get specifically why i figured because i
know these two homosexuals right here
that's why we sit at the same table you
know i know in the military i should
never ask someone who's not uh you know
uh in command or a commander or what an
officer
are you an officer i'm not now i
shouldn't ask them this question
but i will
[Laughter]
what would you have done to get us out
of there or like what would your plan
have been maybe to get out of there i
don't think the afghan army has the
capabilities to
fight alone against a taliban for all
those years they never structured and
developed like any organization or what
was it i mean i think the situation
again is super complex right so i mean
in northern afghanistan the the taliban
owns the cave systems um so how are they
going to get enough firepower or weapons
to destroy them or fight them in the
caves we they need american air support
like they can't go in there with a rifle
trying to fight a war and they'll get
completely annihilated so wow so they
were just waiting so the taliban really
was there just waiting until everything
cleared out and then they just all came
out
i mean
yes it's a certain degree but i mean
taliban also like in plain clothes that
were hiding oh so it's just like the
viet cong
like in the cave system and just
guerilla warfare exactly wow
but for to answer your question like
what specifically like what would what
would i have done in afghanistan or how
i would have gotten the evacuation like
kind of took place
yeah yeah how would how would you have
uh how do you i mean they obviously you
feel like they [ __ ] it up right so so
how would you have done it maybe so like
getting out of afghanistan i 100 would
not have given up any errors fields you
know like in kandahar or bagram like how
are we supposed to get people out how
are we supposed to bring supplies in if
we give up control of that yeah control
and maintain the airfields and i think
we did it too rapidly and i think that
the administration right now way
overestimated the capabilities of the
afghan national army right biden himself
said like hey these people are the best
equipped and trained people because
they've been working with the us for so
long you know but that's not that's not
the situation but obviously our
intelligence agencies are very good at
surveying that situation and going and
giving them the best information
available right
i mean yes but they also aren't the
action side of it you know like who's
going to carry out all the information
someone needs to do the work and that's
the military you know so the ideas guys
always aren't quite as good
as usual
god [ __ ] idea guys
yeah to continue on answering your
questions like create some type of
bubble around kabul as well like hey and
like put it out there like hey if
there's any taliban within these
perimeters we're gonna [ __ ] kill you
yeah you know but that's not the
situation like we're pushing people off
right now like the fences of the airport
so that because i mean we all saw the
videos of people holding on to the gears
of the airplanes and falling off crazy
you know i mean like we don't have that
situation
whatsoever that's crazy i'm sorry repeat
that last part i said we don't have that
situation under control yeah it's been
like a week since we you know like it's
like the fall of saigon literally like
and then there's pictures that show
similarities of people going around it's
nuts yeah and but i mean that picture
doesn't really provide a lot of context
because i mean the air strips or like
the travel route into the u.s embassy in
afghanistan right now it's kind of
blocked off um with the threats are out
there so they've been constantly using
air to go in and out of the embassy so
just because the one helicopter on top
of it doesn't mean like that was the
fall of the embassy um but yeah the
situation but isn't it good that they
left all of our weapons behind
because if they brought them back here
like you know we're like oh no no don't
have weapons here now we're trying to
get rid of the weapons did they grab up
for that reference though they didn't
they grab up a huge weapons cache of
what we had yeah
i think it was
estimated like 88 billion dollars worth
of equipment and
even
were there airplanes and [ __ ] too and i
don't know the full report but i 100
know that we left a [ __ ] ton of like up
armored vehicles that would drive
through banks in the us and nobody would
be able to stop them kind of vehicles
over there and now we just turned it
over to the taliban do you know if what
biden was trying to do is confiscate
more of our ars and give it to them more
stupid that could be good biden's doing
some dumb [ __ ] like that yes
damn man
take that old man but ars are very bad
do you agree
ars are bad no it's a tool
it's a hammer bad sir the way that they
spin a bullet it could kill a human
being
this wasn't if someone threw this hard
enough and spun it hard enough they
could probably kill you not him he'd
drink it faster than he could
i could catch it in my mouth and tip it
back drink it trust me
uh no i remember it was i think it was
beta o'rourke who was saying that about
ar who would say that beto
dude spinning bullets that's cool like
this spins about such a velocity it
kills people it's like
oh yeah
is that right
no way you telling me this well i mean
we wanted the troops out you know it's
weird
and then we get them out but then it's
done so bad
you're setting up like an airspace that
was part of your job before right
through a jtac yep you want to explain
them what you did before it's actually
pretty cool like he jumps out of
airplanes into places that haven't
been established right and you can
establish like you have to like check
the weather and like like how do you how
are you able to as a one individual
set up airspace and like secure it by
yourself
yeah so i mean in afghanistan um in a
place that we own the airspace it's a
lot easier right which is pretty much
everywhere that we own airspace um
except for right now with all the drone
capabilities coming out so that's kind
of a weird situation right now as well
but um i just pretty much go in and then
whenever aircrafts check on station you
just put them in a stack so you put them
in a certain position or altitude um
like let's say they don't have it secure
then they would need to send someone
like you
to jump behind enemy lines right and
you're like yeah but i mean the us has
rarely ever had not had air superiority
so it's like hey we're going to bring in
the f3 like we're going to bring in the
jets you're going to clear the air space
first in any type of war uh before we go
in there and put
walk us through that process that's
crazy so you get on an airplane you have
to jump out attack is a joint tactical
uh terminal attack controller terminal
so like i'm the guy that uh clears the
ordnance off the jet to
drop the bomb or run through the
ordnance meeting
[Laughter]
i'll tell you about it while i bounce
you on my knee young man
but yeah so that's what i did so this
was the job but just controlling
airspace of part of it but there's other
guys from the air force that come in and
run like a whole tower you know like we
see like lax or whatever that is for
that but it's my job like an air traffic
control tower but out over there like on
their own
yeah in there in the air force yeah so
my job was like hey whatever stack i
control the airspace for my team
but on a higher level a lot more
aircrafts would be someone else's job to
kind of send those route those aircrafts
to me and then i'll use them drop some
bombs and then route them back to them
and then they'll wrap them out are you
allowed to fly a kite while you're doing
it or not
it depends how high the next question i
had
unrolled the kite this is perfect win
for a guy i cleared the airspace
yeah it might depends
you